[Music]
giant gold-digging ants a furious king
who orders the sea to be whipped 300
times and a dolphin that saves a famous
poet from drowning these are just some
of the stories from the histories by
Herodotus an ancient Greek writer from
the 5th century BCE not all the events
in the text may have happened exactly as
Herodotus reported them but this work
revolutionized the way the past was
recorded before Herodotus the past was
documented as a list of events with
little or no attempt to explain their
causes beyond accepting things as the
will of the gods Herodotus wanted a
deeper more rational understanding so he
took a new approach looking at events
from both sides to understand the
reasons for them though he was Greek
Herodotus hometown of Halicarnassus was
part of the Persian Empire he grew up
during a series of wars between the
powerful Persians and the smaller Greeks
and decided to find out all he could
about the subject in Herodotus is
telling the Persian Wars began in 499
BCE when the Athenians assisted a
rebellion by Greeks living under Persian
rule in 490 the Persian King Darius sent
his army to take revenge on Athens but
at the Battle of Marathon the Athenians
won an unexpected victory ten years
later the Persians returned planning to
conquer the whole of Greece under the
leadership of Darius's son Xerxes
according to Herodotus when Xerxes
arrived his million-man army was
initially opposed by a Greek force led
by 300 Spartans at the mountain pass
of thermopylae at great cost to the
Persians the Spartans and their king
leonidas were killed this heroic defeat
has been an inspiration to underdogs
ever since a few weeks later the Greek
Navy tricked the Persian fleet into
fighting in a narrow sea channel near
Athens the Persians were defeated and
Xerxes fled never to return to explain
how these wars broke out and why the
Greeks triumphed Herodotus collected
stories from all around the
Mediterranean he recorded the
achievements of both Greeks and
non-greeks before they were lost to the
passage of time the histories opens with
the famous sentence Herodotus of
Halicarnassus here displays his
inquiries by Framing the book as an
inquiry Herodotus allowed it to contain
many different stories some serious
others less so
he recorded the internal debates of the
Persian court but also tales of Egyptian
flying snakes and practical advice on
how to catch a crocodile the Greek word
for this method of research is autopsy
meaning seeing for oneself Herodotus was
the first writer to examine the past by
combining the different kinds of
evidence he collected OPS's for
eyewitness accounts a koay or hearsay
and tally galina or tradition he then
used you know may or reason to reach
conclusions about what actually happened
many of the books early readers were
actually listeners The Histories was
originally written in 28 sections each
of which took about four hours to read
aloud as the Greeks increased in
influence and power Herodotus is writing
and the idea of history spread across
the Mediterranean as the first proper
historian Herodotus wasn't perfect on
occasions he favoured the Greeks over
the Persians and was too quick to
believe some of the stories that he
heard which made for inaccuracies
however modern evidence has actually
explained some of his apparently extreme
claims for instance there's a species of
Marmot
in the Himalayas that spreads gold dust
while digging the ancient Persian word
for Marmot is quite close to the word
for ant so Herodotus may have just
fallen prey to a translation error all
in all for someone who was writing in an
entirely new style Herodotus did
remarkably well history right down to
the present day has always suffered from
the partiality and mistakes of
historians Herodotus is method and
creativity
earned him the title that the Roman
author Cicero gave him several hundred
years later the father of history ted-ed
is a non profit if you value our work
please consider supporting it on
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]